governor thank you for talking to us
the the bank of england's
chief uh job is to try to keep inflation
as close to two percent as possible can
you tell us where you're expecting
inflation to go over the next kind of 12
18 24 months well
what we've currently got is is is an
increase in inflation which has really
you know taken hold during this year
um and unfortunately we expect that to
continue over the winter period um
in our latest forecast we think it will
probably peak
yeah sort of spring next year
and then start to come down
around five percent
what we have signaled today and i think
this is the very important thing is that
we do think that interest rates will
need to rise that the official rate will
need to rise
we haven't done it today it was a very
close call today i should emphasize and
the reason we haven't done it is because
we still need in our view to see hard
evidence
particularly of the state of the job
market in this country that's important
the really important question there is
what has how has the ending of the
furlough scheme
affected
the job market labor demands and
therefore what is likely to be wage
demands in this country and we haven't
got any real clear line of sight of that
at the moment
there were far more jobs than people on
the photo scheme at the end than we
thought there would be interestingly
so what is going to happen what's what
has happened to those we have quite a
lot of you know anecdotal evidence we
all go around the country we talk to
people but we want to see the evidence
before we reach a hard and fast judgment
because that's important but for
families who are looking at their cost
of living going up they're looking at
their gas bills they see that inflation
is very real and it's having an impact
on their finances and they look to the
bank and the bank isn't acting well can
i just be be clear on that so we have to
look at the causes of inflation
many of the causes of inflation at the
moment would not be tackled directly by
raising interest rates it wouldn't
produce more gas it wouldn't produce
more semiconductor chips
to allow more cars to come onto the
market for instance
um you know it wouldn't tackle any of
those in what i call supply chain issues
will not be tackled
and indeed actually it would have the
worst effect it would raise interest
rates it would it would it would slow
down the economy and it would probably
cause unemployment to rise
now we will
we will have to take that step if we
think that there is a risk to the
economy in terms of it overheating
but it would not be the right answer
to a shortage of gas
to raise interest rates if the only
thing we had at the moment was a
shortage of gas that would not be the
right answer
final thing um as bank official governor
looking there at five percent potential
inflation
what does that inspire in your mind do
you feel comfortable with it do you feel
uncomfortable about it i don't think any
and i don't think any governor of the
bank of india would feel comfortable
being in that world
i i understand and we spend a lot of
time understanding you know why we are
where we are the shocks that are
happening in the world economy and of
course you know we haven't mentioned
covet i mean the difficulty of
the recovery from covet of the world
economy from covid but of course we want
to get back to back to the inflation
target as soon as possible and all our
thinking is directed at what is the
what is the best route back to the
inflation target for the economy as a
whole